when a One Direction Getting Back
Together there you go there you go
another point to me
I've got no idea hopefully one day
hopefully hi I'm Louis Tomlinson and I'm
going to find out what the lad Bible
audience think about me let's have a
look
[Music]
who who would Louis Tomlinson most like
to play him in a bio Pig
who do you think now Brad Pitt no idea
um
oh sorry I'm not Timothy
shalamet yeah sorry I I'm just not great
I've got a picture of you God I
recognize him
no that was rude that was rude let me do
that again let me do that again that was
too rude that was too rude okay I'll do
it again
oh yeah I remember
Zac Efron okay HSM era So High School
Musical okay yeah I know I know I can
pictures that yeah can you see the
resemblance uh I'll take it like a good
looking lady
um Harry Styles yeah a little bit close
to her Tom Holland it that's Spider-Man
in there yeah
um oh I've got a good picture of him as
well
[Applause]
I think he wants did something pretty
sound about me to be fair so I'm gonna
go with time I'm gonna go with Tom
Holland which of these nicknames do you
think Louise most fond of right Louis I
have to carry out here these are from
the internet okay okay so like I'm
already a little bit worried don't be
worried but just to say that this was
just from the internet so Dave you've
not come up with these not personally no
all right cool let's have a look
oh dear now the Sass Master From
Doncaster that sounds [ __ ] foul sorry
Luigi I get it open on my name clever
these
oh she got boo bear horrible Lou but
surely Lou it's the most obvious little
abbreviation of me name is it not
um yeah I'll go with low okay
yeah there we go there we go that's
point to me if Lou if Louie I'm using my
nickname
if uh the flu was a cartoon character
which would he be Shaggy from Scooby-Doo
yeah great Pig again
this is him
Blazer yeah okay yeah that's a good pick
okay let me just get the second one as
well
Bart Simpson yeah so that's Bart yeah
and then number one
do you think no I do even with those
clothes to be fair
I'm gonna have to have a look yeah go
for it Timmy Turner who's that
oh
um
that's a random one
um oh damn I personally I've been Shaggy
from Scooby-Doo
okay what is Louis Tomlinson's best
feature
[Music]
right more souls Style
tattoo collection that's a funny
articulation
smile hair all very complementary
um what do I have got no idea what
people have picked let's have a look
[Music]
smile
very nice give
[Laughter]
it
but the four percent on the muscles I
mean I just I'm not gonna lie listen I'd
love to stand here and say I'm surprised
about the four percent of the muscles
but I'm not willing to be honest I'm not
not been to the gym in the last five
years so that's what happens in it what
question is Louis Tomlinson most tired
of being asked what do you think has
come up here oh when in One Direction
Getting Back Together definitely that
happens all the time
why did One Direction break up I was on
the right lines I was on the right lines
yeah
are you single okay
predictable
when in One Direction Getting Back
Together there you go there you go
another point to me do you have an
answer to that I've got no idea
hopefully one day hopefully
Louis Tomlinson wasn't a singer which of
these jobs do you think he would excel
at
what do you think first up might have
been on the doll to be fair
um I would have been and what I would
have loved to have been I would love to
have been a teacher actually but I don't
know if I'd ever got there I'm about to
probably go to UNI for that
um that's what I would have liked to
have been trying to teach you to be fair
but let's see what the public think
actor fan of being an actor maybe
potentially
um something so I mean I'm not gonna be
cool like that not really football oh
wow these are nice aren't they
um
yeah I played a bit of football to be
honest I say this whole time when you're
in a band with four other footballers it
makes you look pretty good to be fair
now was pretty good now was pretty good
right last one this most common is it
McDonald's worker right up my street I
actually uh I applied at McDonald's when
they're about 17 and I got knocked back
so I might have never made it there
either to be fair you have 24 hours with
Louis what are you going to do
interested by these supplies already go
on a full day tour of Doncaster
they're pretty short talk
do a pizza roll what's that mukbang
what's that so that's like this craze
online where they film you it's like a
tick tock thing yeah knew it yeah if
they film you eating yeah yeah so do you
like Pizza Hut I love pizza right so
basically you just eat as much Pizza Hut
as you can so it basically we call that
Buffet Buckle yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
another it's another word for it I think
it's a South Korean thing okay
watch X Factor reruns
for 20 more hours
yes intense sounds like torture
um picnic and Prosecco in the part we
use dogs I mean honestly you don't know
me very well if you think that's what
we're doing
um I think people probably said go on a
full day tour at Doncaster I'll give you
a good tour I reckon okay
you [ __ ] you take it you take it there
must be windy up with that one yeah I
don't know if I've ever had a glass of
Prosecco in my life out of these venues
which did Louis enjoy the most it's a
good question right let's have a look
shower funny very funny
Madison Square Garden
let's compare the two really
X Factor stage
oh London 2012 Olympic Games closing
ceremony perfect time for me to brag and
when I have to say my own my own pick
would definitely be the Olympics that
was an incredible thing to do really
really proud to be involved in all of
that what do I think people appear
there's a lot of comedians out there
they probably pick shower
oh no look look I got it right there you
go London 2012.
um Madison Square Garden another amazing
time and first time he played that as a
band all our family came a few friends
were there as well it was about a really
special time for us and X Factor
obviously where we all had our come up I
do still sing at shower every day to be
fair so I don't know whatever's on my
mind yeah you know what I mean whatever
I'm feeling on the day if Louis was part
of another band which of these would he
be in all right take that
BTS right
Arctic Monkeys better Backstreet Boys
Oasis
the lie I never really take that fan
don't know much of bts's music
don't really know too much of Backstreet
Boys are in the singles so I'm gonna go
with what do I think people are probably
gonna say take that because I was in it
let's have a look
there we go another point to me you see
you see are you I know the public what
would you want to be in like just it's
in our question to answer really I mean
I love Arctic Monkey just from just uh
down the road from where I'm from
Sheffield I'm Louis Tomlinson and that
was ask the audience on lab Bible
just to let you know that one person did
say naked attraction really yeah well
that's obviously my biggest fan what is
naked attraction oh it's that show you
dirty
hi guys I am Tom Holland and today I'm
going to find out what the lab Bible
audience thinks of me I'm very nervous